Also Spieler 10 mit Abspann 11 Chapters, also dass ihr so ungefähr abschätzen könnt.
Da haben wir den ersten Stream dabei, der wird sich vielleicht noch daran erinnern, das ist das, wo wir uns am Hafen auf das Boot gestelzt haben, hier irgendwo durch.
Oder, ne, darum sind wir, hier sind wir in das Boot gegangen.
Und ich glaube, hier es gibt das Speedrun auch.
Ich glaube, der Speedrun skippt irgendwie direkt, hallo, skippt irgendwie direkt zu hier mit rumgeglitsche, also er spielt das halbe Game gar nicht.
Oh, der wird gestelzt, der Typ, der wird gestelzt.
Der wird gestelzt.
Bam, Stelzkill.
Bam, bam, bam.
Bam.
Bam, zack, da geht er down.
Was, der Stream war down?
Ja, das lag aber an Twitch, oder?
Nö, ich habe das nicht mitgekriegt, dass der Stream down war.
Ha, lull.
Das lag aber an Twitch, oder? Oder lag das an mir?
Zwei Minuten oder so.
Ha.
Habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Ähm, was war denn das letzte von dem Game, was ihr gesehen habt?
Ja, ich gucke nicht immer auf die Vorschau.
Ne, den F-Spam habe ich nicht gesehen.
Dann war es vielleicht die Telekom wieder.
Ach, ernsthaft? Die Devs, die nicht kommunizieren.
Die Devs, die nicht...
Das heißt, ihr habt noch nicht mal den Levelwechsel gesehen, oder?
Habt ihr den Levelwechsel gesehen?
Ne.
Okay, mal gucken, ob ich noch was zum Laden habe.
Leider nicht.
Im Prinzip war das aber auch am Ende des Levels.
Wir sind mit dem Boot wieder zurück in die Anfangsstadt gefahren und müssen jetzt halt den bösen Necromancer aufhalten.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Es lag bestimmt an der Telekom.
Es könnte aber auch an Twitch liegen, man weiß das nicht so genau.
Telekom-Stabilität ist so fail in letzter Zeit.
Habt ihr auch nicht gesehen, wie cool ich die Wachen gebasht habe?
Oh.
Äh.
Schreckt.
Ich habe es leider verkackt dieses Jahr.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich ursprünglich Unity Media abbestellen.
Weil ich mir so gedacht habe, okay, kein Mensch braucht zwei Internetanschlüsse.
Vor allem, wenn der zweite Internetanschluss...
50 Euro im Monat kostet.
Oder sogar noch mehr.
Ich glaube 60 oder so.
Und ich wollte im Endeffekt Unity Media abbestellen und nur noch für Fernsehen da lassen.
Und den Rest wieder über die Telekom.
Weil bei Telekom habe ich ja eh mittlerweile VDSL.
Und ich brauche halt ordentlichen Upload.
Für Stremsor und Zeug.
Und ich habe es dieses Jahr verkackt zu kündigen bei Unity Media.
Ich habe den Monat verpasst.
Ich hätte im August kündigen müssen.
Zwei Monate vorher habe ich verpasst.
Und so im Nachhinein bin ich eigentlich ganz froh, weil die Zuverlässigkeit der Telekom ist so unter aller Sau.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das hinkriegt.
Also das Telekom Internet, das ist teilweise Sonntagmorgens immer eine Stunde weg.
Und ich denke, wie kriegt man das hin?
Das ist wirklich, das ist ganz kreudig von der Telekom.
Der wird gebasht.
Damn.
Hallo, lass mich rein.
Ach, die lassen mich wirklich rein.
Das ist aber sehr nett von euch.
Achtung.
Der wird jetzt geschreckt.
Bam.
Da ist er down.
Der braucht Bücher.
Telekom ist halt shit, ja.
Ich verstehe es halt echt nicht, wie man das hinkriegen kann.
Es ist so schlecht.
Unity Media ist in dem Fall besser.
Unity Media hat aber keinen gescheiten Upload.
Vielleicht können wir den Dude stelzen, hä?
Gucken wir mal, ob der an uns vorbeiläuft.
Ganz Deutschland Internet ist shit hier leider.
Komm her.
Ja.
Krasser Bogey-Stelzer.
Da bist du gemessert.
Debated.
Okay, die machen nicht auf.
Ich muss mich überlegen, ne?
Ich bezahle jetzt quasi irgendwie 120 Euro für Internet und Fernsehen im Monat.
Wegen zwei Anbietern.
Das ist eigentlich komplett lächerlich, ne?
Qualitätseinstellungen sind wieder weg.
Ist denn wenigstens 1080p noch da?
Hallo?
Warum sieht er mich nicht?
Ist er komplett beschränkt oder was?
Oh, der hat mich gesehen.
Oh, was geht denn ab?
Der ist aber richtig mal Speed unterwegs.
Alter, ist jetzt noch das Game ge...
Was ist denn jetzt gerade los?
Ey, jetzt ist aber alles am verrecken gerade.
Was sagt eigentlich OBS?
Läuft der Stream wenigstens ordentlich jetzt?
Ja.
Gut.
Das ist gerade gegen uns.
So, wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben jetzt überhaupt?
Ah, hier sind wir.
Oh, wir haben den Typen noch nicht gestellt.
Egal.
Scheiß drauf.
YOLO.
Wir haben eh ein Nahkampfbild.
Alter, warum ist der Typ...
Der ist so schnell und die normalen Wachen so lahm.
Das ist Special-Wache hier.
Nein, nein, wir machen keine Hebel auf.
Keine Hebel aufmachen.
Oh.
Jetzt werden die immer mehr.
Oh, Kopf ab.
Ein Bogey.
Da, mach.
Warum schießt der durch mein Schild?
Achtung.
Messer.
Bam.
Oh, da fliegt er.
Fünf Kigerbein.
Ja.
Wofür...
Man hat Ram jetzt vom Verwenden.
Ja, wozu hat man viel Ram, wenn man das Ram nicht verwendet?
Oh.
NA.
NA-Aim mit dem Schwert.
Jetzt werden sie geownt.
Bam.
Oh, den hat's zerrissen.
Den hat's richtig zerrissen.
Jetzt können wir das Live-Lead-Schwert nehmen.
Dann kriegen wir wieder mehr Health.
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit
selber mit 2 Terabyte Ram.
Also, da gehen immer noch mehr.
Oh, die kriegen aber echt faul auf die Fresse.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Das Ding ist übelst undurchsichtig.
Wo ist hier was?
Wo geht's hier lang?
Das ist...
Ich glaub's nicht.
Er hat sich meinem Stelz-Attempt widersetzt.
So, gibt's hier irgendwas zu looten?
Nope.
Da, doch.
Loot.
Futter.
Health Cat.
Oh, was?
Was hab ich aufgehoben?
Was?
Wo ist mein Food?
Das ist ein Leben.
Live-Lead-Schwert.
Weiter geht's.
Ähm, aus welcher Richtung bin ich denn jetzt gekommen eigentlich?
Da?
Oh, hier geht's weiter.
Ich geh nochmal zurück.
Ich will wissen, was auf der anderen Seite ist.
Ich hab bestimmt irgendwas verpasst.
Weil man konnte ja einmal linksrum, einmal rechtsrum gehen.
Ich bin linksrum gegangen.
Was zum Teufel soll Ram-Tafeln sein?
Ah, jetzt gehen wir mal in die andere Richtung.
So.
Ist das Dark Souls Royale?
Ja.
Ja, richtig.
Early Access.
Von den DayZ-Machern.
Nee, sorry, nicht.
Von den Warts-Machern ist das.
Also, das ist quasi...
Ähm, die...
Das war blöde.
Die Warts-Typen, die haben doch bestimmt schon extra Battle Royale, oder?
Das haben die sich doch nicht entgehen lassen, da auch die Leute wieder zu scammen.
Warts.
Weil, die ist ja gar nix.
So ein Portal, ja.
Da kommen wir her, das weiß ich.
Hier ist Loot.
Und hier ist...
Ah, nee, hier waren wir noch nicht.
Interessant.
Doch.
Hier haben wir die Gegner vorhin geschnitzelt.
Hier ist ja gar nix.
Das hätten wir uns sparen können, hier lang zu gehen.
Aber wir wissen jetzt auch, wir haben nix verpasst.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Fortnite Z.
Das find ich cool.
Aber, nee, die haben...
Das ist Fortnite Z, ist das dann.
Also, man...
Die wollen sich...
Die wollen sich ja nicht verklagen lassen von denen, ne?
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich dann Fortnite Z oder so.
Von denen.
Dass keiner auf die Idee kommt, sie zu verklagen.
Oder Fortnite wie Ritter.
Ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das kann ich mir bei den Typen gut vorstellen.
Aber die haben doch sowas bestimmt.
Die scammasen doch laufen, die Leute.
Ist eigentlich Warts mittlerweile irgendwie fertig?
Moment, ich laufe in die falsche Richtung.
In irgendwie einem Zustand...
Wo das was taugt.
Ich blick nicht durch.
Moment, wo geht's lang?
Fortnite Z.
Fortnite Z find ich aber...
Das ist nice.
Four Nights.
Ja, da gibt's verschiedene Varianten, ne?
Hier sind wir richtig.
Weckt.
Schnells-Mode activated.
Oh, nee, der hat mich gesehen.
Runter mit dir.
Runter mit euch.
Oh, oh, oh!
WTF?
Au!
Die machen ganz schön Damage.
Hast du eigentlich Speer Cops 4, ja?
Ich spiel das sogar ab und zu noch.
Wobei ich ja auch...
dort irgendwie mit dem...
Battle Royale Modus nicht so richtig wahr werde.
Und eher den normalen Multiplayer-Spiel.
Alter, die machen Damage, die Typen.
Ach, das ist das Schwert vom Gegner.
Das ist einfach durch den halben Raum geflogen.
Ach so.
Oh.
Ich hab wenig Leben, doch.
Sagt mir Bescheid, falls der Stream wieder abgekackt ist.
Spielt der Friseur auch COD?
Nein, der hat keinen Bock mehr.
Der hat keinen Bock mehr auf COD.
Auf COD hat er keinen Bock mehr.
Sprich COD.
Sprich das bitte korrekt aus, Max.
Es ist nicht COD, es ist COD.
Die Leute immer früher auf YouTube, ne?
Training Area.
Da kommen wir nicht weiter.
Der Fabian, der spielt seit, also der Friseur, der spielt seit irgendwie zwei Jahren oder so, nur BDO.
Oh, nice.
Bam!
Moment, dazu müssen wir uns unsere Daggers rausholen wieder.
Flop.
Oh, das sind die guten.
Das sind die upgraden.
Upgraden Guards.
Frenzy Fire.
Oh, nice.
Wo ist der andere?
Komm her.
Zack.
Gesplatter.
Gibt's hier noch Loot?
Das war's immer noch nicht.
Dann kriegt er jetzt ein Fass an den Kopf.
Oh, nein.
Der will kein Fass an den Kopf.
Ich will aber nicht ein Fass an den Kopf werfen.
Oh, WTF?
Die haben mich geownt.
Ich halte das Gegner.
Das ist, das ist per Definition, dürfen die das nicht.
Dafür werden sie jetzt krass geschreckt.
Bam, next.
Zack.
Jetzt machen wir keine schönen Kills.
Jetzt wird alles weggeschnetzelt.
Komm her.
Oh.
Sneaky.
Alter, warum machen die so viel Damage?
Gibt's ja gar nicht.
Ich könnte ja auch, ich könnte ja auch Heiltränke nehmen.
Aber Heiltränke sind komplett overrated.
Es muss ohne Heiltränke gehen.
Das ist es.
Oh, jawoll.
Oh, nice.
Alle weggeschnetzelt.
So muss das sein.
Jawoll.
Und wieder volle Leben.
Lifelead-Schwert-FTW-Aste.
Alles weggekloppt.
Was haben wir hier?
Ah.
Der Schlüssel.
Das ist der Schlüssel.
Das ist der Schlüssel für diese komische Tür da vorne.
Oh, wir können was specken.
Was haben wir denn?
Ah, wir warten noch ein Skillpunkt, dann specken wir Adrenalin.
Dann können wir das.
Dann können wir zwei Finisher ausführen.
Äh, wie ich falsch rumlaufe.
So mit Orientierung habe ich es nicht so, das wisst ihr ja.
Only in Battlefield.
Das haben sie dieses Mal nicht so wirklich zelebriert, ne?
Dieses Only in Battlefield Geschichte bei Battlefield 5.
Ich habe eh das Gefühl, Battlefield 5, außer so 0815 Werbesprüche, die sie immer machen,
so nach dem Motto, oh schaut mal hier, das geilste Level aller Zeiten.
Oh schaut mal hier, ist das ein geiles Game.
So wirklich was zeigen, so eine wirkliche Strategie scheinen sie diesmal nicht zu verfolgen, ne?
Bei Battlefield 4 haben sie die Evolution angepriesen, ja.
Bei Battlefield 1 haben sie sich aufgegeilt an dem Setting.
Aber bei Battlefield 5, ich weiß gar nicht, was da so ihre Standard-Marketing-Strategie ist.
Aber das rettet das Game wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, Battlefield 5 rettet nichts mehr.
Vielleicht der Battlefield 5.
Vielleicht der Battle Royale-Modus, so was Spielerzahlen angeht, wenn er was taucht.
Vielleicht.
Eher nicht.
Äh.
Okay, man kann sie nicht, nicht killen.
Aha, was ist denn das?
Äh.
Hallo, andere Richtung klettern bitte.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet?
WTF?
Ach, das ist einfach nur um den Fight zu umgehen.
Oh, da ist was. Da ist was. Was ist denn da?
Ein Secret Items?
Hier, das bringt es nicht, wirklich.
Guck mal, wo es hier lang geht.
Hallo, Fass.
Ich bin gestunt!
Ich bin gestunt, ich glaube es geht los.
Hier wird nicht gestunt.
Hier wird geschnetzelt.
Ist aber. Ja, jetzt ist er down.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob auch das ganz gut ist.
Oh, da ist eine geheime Tür hochgegangen ist.
Unten im Keller.
Wut!
Schon fast Zombie-Stells.
Okay, Gegengift.
Hier ist nix.
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal schnell, was rechts in dem Raum gewesen ist.
Komischen Staff brauchen wir nicht. Sackt.
Äh, Moment.
Kommen wir von hier?
Ne, wir kommen von da, ne?
Wo geht es denn hier hinten lang?
Plate Armor haben wir schon.
Verschlossen.
Ach, hier geht es weiter.
Okay, da gucken wir erstmal, was hinten in der Tür war.
Mein Gott, das Level ist aber echt verwirrend.
Das ist aber nix.
Könnt ihr euch noch an 4 erinnern?
Das ist aber nix gegen die Schalter-Rätsel und
Spielereien von 4.
Da hast du nämlich gar nicht durchgeblickt.
Ich habe echt meinen Zweifel, dass Battlefield was wird.
Dass 5 war...
Ich kann auch die Logik nicht verstehen, warum man das...
Na, der Raum ist ja nicht so groß jetzt.
Warum man das wirklich 5 nennt, aber das ist halt...
...die Marketing-Taktik.
Die ich halt auch nicht verstehe, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil ich keinen Sinn darin erkenne, aber...
...ist halt so.
Ist so, wie es ist. In dem Fall können wir da wirklich nix dran machen.
Shadowsteel-Dagger, die haben wir auch schon.
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal schnell, ob die Tür unten auf ist.
Im Geheimraum.
Jawoll! Oder?
Ne.
Da.
Kann man die Tür direkt aufmachen.
Kann man nicht.
Okay, Max. Pech gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Pech gehabt, würde ich sagen.
Ich muss hier unten raus.
So, gehen wir weiter.
Wo war jetzt die richtige...
...Tür? Da, ne?
Verwirrende Level.
Da habe ich zu small...
...zu small das Brain für.
Moin, Sweet.
Gehts weiter, ne?
Ja, ich hätte auch lieber im Gegenwart
Battlefield.
Ich finde es immer...
Ich finde die Argumentation von den Ultra-Battlefield-Fans
immer geil.
Das Wizard-Grill lebt!
Ich rette das Wizard-Grill!
Ich war nicht schnell genug
mit meinen...
...mit meinen Snipe-Künsten.
Aber nachdem ich das Game
schon kenne, weiß ich, was kommt.
...
3 und 4 habt ihr immer alle geheult, es ist
nur Gegenwart, dann kamen die jetzt mit Battlefield
1 um die Ecke und ihr seid immer noch am Heulen.
Und jetzt machen sie
Battlefield 2, äh, was sind
Battlefield 5, also im 2. Weltkrieg
und jetzt ist euch das auch nicht recht, oh, ich kann
es ja überhaupt nicht recht machen, oh, DICE ist aber
ganz schön arm dran, die reden sich das alles
übel schön, ja, und
man muss es ja auch mal ehrlich sagen,
es ist eigentlich scheißegal,
in welchem Setting das ist. Ich hätte
mir persönlich würde halt ein modernes Setting am
besten gefallen, aber das Wichtigste
ist, dass das Game im Kern
was taugt, was halt Battlefield 1
meiner Meinung nach überhaupt nicht gemacht hat.
Oh, den hat es aber instant zerlegt, ey.
Mal gucken, ob wir
was stelzen können.
I want here.
Ist der French?
Da wäre es, oh, oh,
hier oder so wäre der Typ auf
Französisch. Au!
Gut, dass ihr das
nicht gehört habt da drüben.
Stelzen.
Ja, ja, laber du nur rum.
Achtung, die werden jetzt gestelzt.
Was?
Der hat mich gesehen, Sauerei.
Aber zum Glück
könnt ihr ja nix.
Zum Glück seid ihr so Kack-Noobs.
Kack-Noobs können nix.
Easy clap.
Okay, ähm,
Moment, wird von mir jetzt erwartet, dass
ich dem Wizard-Grill hinterher springe,
um es zu retten.
Ich mag das Wizard-Grill
überhaupt nicht.
Wenn es da weh geht, will mir das gar nicht retten.
Okay, das ist nicht so gedacht.
Ach, da geht's lang.
High-Speed-Door.
Ich frag mich, warum man das halt in so einem Haus,
wo Leute drinnen wohnen, im Endeffekt so baut, ne?
Ich mein, willst du jedes Mal, wenn du aufs Klo musst,
erstmal eine halbe Stunde kurbeln, bis du durchs Tor kannst?
Aber wahrscheinlich,
wenn man Necromancer ist, dann hat man
keine Probleme mit.
Da muss man nicht aufs Klo.
Die machen nix mehr.
Krass aufgelöste
Bodentextur, by the way.
Aber das Spiel ist von 2008.
Ich geb XANA recht.
Aber unser Held,
das ist der Held.
Aber unser Held möchte das Wizard-Grill retten.
Also machen wir das.
Ist hier was?
Nee.
So, nachdem jetzt jetzt ja kein Spoiler mehr ist,
wenn ich sage, dass das Wizard-Grill noch lebt,
ihr könnt euch ja schon mal überlegen,
im nächsten Level müssen wir uns entscheiden,
ob wir auf der Seite von XANA stehen
oder auf der Seite von Liana.
Also sprich, auf der Seite von unserem,
von unserem Succubus im...
Uah!
Im Kopf oder auf der Seite vom Wizard-Grill.
Ups, warum hab ich denn jetzt meine,
äh, nicht Taschenlampe, meine,
ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt,
meine Magic-Taschenlampe angemacht.
Ich find das geil, wie er das Schwert immer raus und...
So ein bisschen wie...
Warte mal.
So ein bisschen wie dieser Salzstreutyp.
Kennt ihr den?
Der, der sich, der sich quasi so dieses Salz
über den, über den Unterarm gleiten lässt
in das Essen. Kennt ihr den?
Diesen Salzstreutyp.
Der macht den Arm auch so ähnlich wieder.
Nee, so nicht.
So nicht, so ja.
Nee, jetzt macht er's nicht mehr.
Egal.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Ich weiß nicht, wie der Typ heißt.
Der, der so Salz streut.
Ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich,
the fuck, was redet der Max wieder für komische Dinger, ey.
Der Salzstreutyp.
Da gab's doch mal nen Typ.
Ja, genau, genau, LastFanboy.
Der, der, der Salt B.
Genau der.
Ja, den mein ich.
Spodas.
Spiderman.
Spas-
Wut
Face
Oh, ja
Okay, jetzt müssen wir die Spoiler noch irgendwie killen
Wie immer wir das genau machen sollen
Wir jumpen da jetzt einfach drauf
Komm her
Au
Okay, ich lad nochmal neu
Das war definitiv nicht so gedacht
Die Spin hat einen Wornhack, eindeutig
Die weiß, wo ich bin
Spider Senses
Wir ownen die Spin einfach so
Kein Ding
Bam
Schild weg, Zweihänder regelt
Wir müssen mal kurz
Heilen
Wie, das hat vorbeigehauen
Oh, Special
Bam, zack, das war ein nice Hit
Ist sie down?
Sie ist down
Jawoll
Da geht's down
Da unten geht's
Alles down
Gut
Wizard Grill einpacken und abhauen, würde ich sagen
Ja, XANA
Ich wollte auch nicht, der Held wollte
Was passiert, ich muss das mal ausprobieren
Was passiert, wenn ich die kille?
Da freut sich XANA bestimmt
What are you doing?
You won't use me anymore, wench
Yes, my love
She's tortured us
Don't let her live
Da, XANA freut sich
Aber ich lad mal neu, wir wollen das Wizard Grill ja nicht killen
Ich mein, ich hab sie erst mal gerettet und jetzt soll ich sie killen
Das wär ja irgendwie ziemlich beklagt, ne
Eine Spawner, die machen wir mal mit Range Attacks platt
Leana, nicht davor rennen
Das, die kennt da nix
Da sieht man einfach mal wieder, wie unfähig Wizard Grills sind
Und das Demon
Guck mal, habt ihr gesehen hier, krasse Environment Effects
Das ist der Mond, nein?
Dat sieht einfach ...
Besser sind, in dem Fall
Das neue Dark Souls sieht komisch aus
Ja ...
So ist das halt mit Early Exits Alphas
Ich darf hier eigentlich gar nicht streamen, das neue Darks Out Exploder
Aber, ich hab mir gedacht
Komm
Scheiß drauf
Darks Zones, NG
Guck mal wie sie ...
Kopf bewegt
Say nothing
You can be cleansed of this
I know a way
I will talk to the priest in the sanctuary here
Also, wie wir schon feststellen,
die beiden Mädels
mögen sich nicht sonderlich.
Naja, das war jetzt schon
ein krasser Cheap Bait, oder?
Ich finde das offensichtlich, dass es
nicht die Dark Souls
Early Access Alpha ist.
Aber könnte sein. Man weiß ja nie.
Moment. Liana, wo bist du hin?
Die hat keinen Bock.
Die bleibt jetzt einfach da stehen.
Also,
wenn ich der krasse
Ober-Nekro
Mancer-Anführer bin, dann würde ich
natürlich auch mein Tagebuch
mitten in mein Zimmer stellen.
Auf so einem riesen fetten Buch,
dass es jeder lesen kann.
So, das ist es. Aber gut, ich meine,
wenn man der Böse ist in so einer Story,
dann macht man halt einfach so Dinger.
Gut, wir haben das jetzt gelesen.
Oh, jetzt ist er böse.
Jetzt ist er mad. Jetzt will er so auen.
Hast du schon mal CTF
Hacking Challenges gemacht? CTF?
Okay.
Capture the Flag?
Was? Nee.
Liana, gegen ADAD-Spam kommst du eh nicht an.
ADAD-Spam ist
in jedem Game einfach
das Beste.
Hittet mich keiner.
Auf geht's. Komm mit.
Move dich.
Ja, Capture the Flag. Was sind denn
Capture the Flag Hacking Challenges?
Was genau soll das sein?
Sagt mir nix.
Du bleibst mal hier.
Hier bleiben.
Mach das.
Moment.
Da ist er noch.
Ja.
Das war's.
Buff Food.
Noch ein bisschen Buff Food.
Äh, ist ja gar kein Buff Food.
Schwachsinn. Äh, äh.
Health Food.
Jawoll.
Let's go.
Ach so.
Nee, hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Zeit, hab ich noch nicht.
Ach man.
Wow, da fliegt er.
Wie, der lebt noch?
Der lebt noch?
Warum lebt denn der Typ so lang?
Jetzt aber.
Oh, die machen mir ein bisschen viel Damage, die Jungs hier.
Die Typen machen mir ein bisschen viel Damage.
Aber das war ja auch wieder ein total bescheuertes Opening.
Eigentlich wollte ich den Typen messern.
Und der andere Dude hat mich gesehen.
Wir warten, bis er vorbei ist.
Dann messern wir den einen.
Dann holen wir das Zweihänder-Schwert.
Raus.
Und alle werden gemount.
Mein Baum, kommst du jetzt zu mir?
Ah.
Okay, Schwert raus.
Das mit Stels, das wird nichts mehr.
Komm.
Weiter.
Vira ausweicht.
Vira ausweicht?
Der erlaubt sich aber was.
Oh, hinter mir, hinter mir, hinter mir.
Wo ist noch was?
Wo ist denn der passende?
Wo ist der passende?
Da ist der Necromancer dazu, da unten.
Komm her.
Bam.
Zack.
Die halten aber auch was aus.
Wie viel will der Typ noch aushalten?
Ich hab den achtmal gehittet oder so.
Jetzt, jetzt hat er down.
Okay.
Du willst halt Grill abholen?
Leana, wo steckst du?
Du darfst mitkommen.
Auf.
Ich hab aufgeräumt.
Hier war doch irgendwo noch eine Tür zum Aufmachen gerade.
Äh, warum es keinen Nachfolger gab, das frage ich mich bis heute.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es kommerziell nicht so erfolgreich war.
Aber es wäre geil.
Weil ich, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, es hat das beste Nahkampf-Kampfsystem, was ich je gesehen habe in einem Game.
Hier gibt es noch was zum Aufmachen.
Nichts mehr.
Ja.
Juice.
The Juice ist hier.
Aufpassen, dass ich Leana nicht haue.
Okay, wir kommen von da.
Das heißt, wir müssen nach hier.
Ja.
Kommt sie?
Also, wie gesagt, ich finde es schade, dass sich das Game nicht gut verkauft hat und dass es keinen Nachfolger gibt.
Das ist wirklich blöd.
Oh, ich hab schon gedacht, das Game wäre geclasht.
Und tschüss.
Ach nee.
Ich hab das nicht verstanden.
Ich dachte, ich kann sie runterfahren.
Ich muss...
Ich muss einfach kurz kicken.
Lass die Feministen sehen.
Person an sich macht das Spiel zu einem
Amoklauf-verherrlichten Killerspiel.
Alles.
Nicht Amoklauf-Killerspiele.
Alles sind
ganz schrecklich.
Teufelszeug.
Moment.
Wisst ihr, was ich gut finde
bei dieser ganzen Killerspiel-Diskussion?
Dass es die Diskussion eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt.
Irgendwelche Leute
bei RTL oder so werben das
zwar ab und zu nochmal auf,
aber in der heutigen Zeit, es ist einfach Mainstream.
Wie ich im letzten Video gesagt habe.
Mesut Özil hat eine
E-Sport-Organisation der eigenen.
Oder
viele Leute, ja.
Und das ist einfach mittlerweile im Mainstream angekommen.
Das heißt, die Diskussion hat sich erledigt.
Bis auf Leute wie der Pfeiffer
oder der, wie heißt der andere?
Der Spitzer? Den gibt es ja auch noch.
Der Spitzer erzählt ja auch immer,
wie geschädigt
das für das kindliche Gehirn ist und sowas.
Ähm.
Was macht eigentlich Regine Pfeiffer?
Ja.
Ja, außerdem
kräht da kein Hahn mehr nach.
Ja, aber die sterben aus.
Ist so.
Ja, sterben aus.
Also im Prinzip ist der Kampf,
was Killerspiele...
Oh Mensch, ich laufe in die falsche Richtung.
Diese Anti-Killer-Spiel-Sache oder
der Kampf für, äh,
Games in der Gesellschaft, so anerkennend
und das ist gewonnen. Ja, den gibt's nicht.
Den gibt's nicht mehr, der ist vorbei.
Da haben wir gesiegt, quasi, in dem Fall.
Hättest du gleich aufmachen können.
Bogen brauchen wir nicht.
Arrows nehmen wir mit.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ach stimmt, ich darf den da gar nicht killen.
Ich bin der ADAD-Spammer.
Oh, sicher.
Durch die Aqueducts.
Wie kommen wir da hin?
Wie?
Sag es mir schnell.
Komm schon.
So forcivoll.
Es ist ein Cyclops, der sich direkt über den Weg sitzt.
Niemand kommt mit ihm.
Geh in die Maut-Kontrollhaus und ich werde dich inszenieren.
Aber jetzt ist es ein undeiner Cyclops draußen.
Undeiner Cyclops, das ist eines meiner leichtesten Übungen,
das Viech zu ownen.
Oder führ es weg, während ich...
Wir wissen ja mittlerweile, wie das geht.
Keine großartigen Taktik-Spiele.
Keine großen Taktiken probieren,
sondern einfach fünfmal Jump-Slashen und down ist er.
Skillpoints.
Wir kriegen so viele Skillpoints,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich skillen soll.
Als nächstes skillen wir Endu.
So, machen wir den Cyclops mal down.
Wo geht es denn hier lang?
Nice.
Voll ins Auge getroffen.
Komm her.
Jetzt wirst du gebasht.
Bam.
Die können nix.
Scheiß auf Taktik.
Guck mal.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Jump-Slash.
Power-Attack.
Down ist er.
Piss dich.
Oh fuck.
Ich darf den da nicht hauen.
Oh, wo geht es hier lang?
Also, bevor wir jetzt da lang gehen, gucken wir erstmal, wo es hier in dem Kanal reinging.
Weil wir wollen ja keine Secret-Areas und Skillpoints und Zeug verpassen.
Ähm.
Oh.
Leitern in Spielen, das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Okay, ich drück nach unten
und er geht nach oben und ich drück nach oben
und er geht nach unten.
Okay, jetzt.
Oh, Leiter-Action.
Source-Leitern, ja, Source-Leitern sind fast,
sind mit die Schlimmsten.
Aber Half-Life-1-Leitern waren auch schon so.
Half-Life-1-Eitern war das Schlimmste,
Eitern? Ja, genau, also Half-Life-1-Eitern
war das Schlimmste.
Da bist du nämlich gleich schnell
hoch wie gelaufen und bist dann so
geslided so irgendwie an der Leiter.
Oh, ein
Mana-und-Life-Auffüllpilz.
Get schreckt!
Oh, hier geht's
rein.
Wo geht's denn hier lang? Gibt's Loot?
Erstmal die Einrichtung demolieren.
Kiste.
Heiltränke, die nehmen wir mit.
Geht's hier hoch?
Und hier war doch irgendwo
eine Leiter.
Ich finde es gut, dass
meine Magietaschenlampe kein
Mana kostet.
Ne, ich glaube, das war einfach nur
ein extra Weg, den Zyklop zu killen.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Overrated.
Outdated.
Gebaited.
Ja, das war nur ein extra Weg, den Zyklop zu
killen.
Ein Schlüssel, vielleicht kann ich jetzt oben aufmachen.
Top Secret.
Revealed.
Ah, war jetzt aber nicht so geil.
Okay.
Gab's ja im Endeffekt nichts, außer einen Hellstrank.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich meine Aussprache von
Hells?
Die ist schon, die ist schon eigentlich
ziemlich nah an dem, wie sie sein sollte, oder?
Hellstrank.
Aber ich finde, da gibt's nicht mal viel
Verbesserungspotenzial.
Kann ich hier runter?
Hallo? Runter?
Muss ich jetzt wirklich runterlaufen, ja?
Der Hellstrank.
Der Stelser trinkt einen Hellstrank.
So, auf geht's.
Ja, ist, ist doch.
Oh.
Der Typ ist verbuggt, oder?
Ich glaub, der Typ ist verbuggt.
Der Dude ist verbuggt und ich hab gesaved.
Oh nee, oder?
Der Typ ist bugged.
Scheiße.
Scheiße, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Autosave.
Wir haben noch einen Autosave.
Der Typ ist bugged. Geil.
Aber wir haben noch einen Autosave.
Ha.
Nein.
Alter.
Nicht Ease.
Okay, ähm.
Wartet mal, Leute.
War jetzt irgendwas, irgendwas Gutes
hier im Secret-Raum?
Nee, ne? Da war nur Mist.
Da müssen wir nicht nochmal hin.
Aber den Schlüssel nehmen wir mal mit.
Den Schlüssel nehmen wir mal mit.
Vielleicht können wir damit später noch andere Türen aufmachen.
Schlüssel sind nie verkehrt zu haben.
Ah.
Moment, wo war denn jetzt der Schlüssel überhaupt?
Andere Seite, ne?
Lull.
Schlüssel nehmen wir noch mit.
Im Prinzip, Schlüssel nehmen wir noch mit, heißt,
wir machen den ganzen Weg nochmal.
Weil der Weg nicht lang ist.
Ist ja nur hier runter jetzt.
Ah, hier können wir auch aufschließen.
Da haben wir noch gar nicht reingeguckt.
Hier waren wir noch gar nicht.
Nix drin.
Nix.
Moment.
Was zum Teufel?
Secret Area ohne was drin.
Ach nee, da ist eine Truhe.
Mit einer Health-Potion.
Krasses Secret Area.
Dafür muss man unbedingt einen eigenen Raum machen,
dass man da eine Health-Potion drin verstecken kann.
Hier war auch nur Crap drin, ne?
Ja.
Grabber, Z.
Volle Health.
Jawoll.
Okay, jetzt können wir speichern.
Jetzt ist der Typ ja durchgelaufen.
So.
Kannst du mit zwölf Skill-Points nicht die nächsten Skill freischalten?
Muss ich mal gucken.
Ähm.
Ja.
Boah, krasser, stylischer Jumper.
Ich mag Spiele, wo man in der Luft steuern kann, wo man hinfällt.
Komm her.
Okay, jump, Percy!
The bridge!
Are you alright?
I'll try to find another way through.
If I can, I'll run around and meet you just up the street.
Da kommt man doch rüber, oder?
If we didn't need him...
Ja, easy.
Kommt man da rüber.
Wenn das nicht...
Wenn da keine Wand wäre.
If we didn't need him, I'd tell him to just keep running.
Annoying man.
And then keep him busy.
Was jetzt?
Game Crash?
Alter Falter.
Ey.
Das ist aber ein Win aus 10 Problem.
Das Game ist früher nie gecrashed.
Ich kann mich da nicht dran erinnern, dass das früher auch so viel gecrashed wäre.
Das ist ein Problem mit Win aus 10.
Das hab ich auch schon gelesen.
Das spackt rum.
RIP.
Ja.
So, dann können wir jetzt die Typen nochmal outen.
Oh, den hat's aber zerrissen, richtig.
Bam!
Kopf in die Wand.
Der Flick!
Habt ihr den gesehen, hä?
360 Bein abhackflip.
Flick.
Nicht flip.
Das hat sich nicht gelohnt.
Was wir den Schlüssel mitgenommen haben.
Es gibt in dem Spiel kein, ähm, Rechtssystem oder so.
Also kein, kein irgendwie Gesinnungssystem.
Du kannst alles killen, was du willst.
Es juckt nicht.
Solange es nicht questrelevant ist, ist es vollkommen egal.
Du kannst auch jegliche Wache bashen.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
So, Leute.
Jetzt müssen wir uns entscheiden.
Ob wir...
Das Game hat vier verschiedene Enden.
Ich kann...
Also, ich kann euch nicht alle Enden erzählen.
Weil, das wird noch...
Andere Sachen spoilern.
Aber, die Enden unterscheiden sich, je nachdem, welches Mädel man auswählt, ja?
Also, an der Stelle haben wir jetzt hier einmalig die Gelegenheit, quasi uns von XANA zu reinigen.
Da kann man in so einen Tempel gehen und dann ist sie weg.
Und das findet das Wizard-Grill ganz toll.
Und die, äh, findet einen dann ganz, ganz geil, ja?
Oder aber, man lässt das Ganze bleiben.
Dann findet ein XANA übelst geil.
Und das Wizard-Grill hasst einen.
Was wollen wir machen?
Ich persönlich bin ja der Meinung, Wizard-Grill ist das Beste.
Äh, nicht Wizard-Grill.
Äh, Demon-Grill ist das Beste.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns aber angucken, was passiert.
Wir können mal ein Save punkten.
Wir können mal...
Wir können mal safen.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir mal...
Gucken, was passiert, wenn wir das Demon-Grill austreiben.
Isabel.
Was ist das für eine Stämme?
Es riecht wie Drogen-Magie.
Du kannst nicht...
Wir können uns ja mal angucken, wie das aussieht.
Wir laden das aber neu, weil ich will das Demon-Grill behalten.
Lol.
Oh, eine nice Rüstung.
Hat sich doch gleich mal Endo-3-Specken gelohnt.
Aber wir können ja nicht speichern.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Was passieren würde, wenn wir...
Wenn wir das Demon-Grill austreiben.
Aus uns.
Klingt irgendwie komisch.
Aber das machen wir nicht.
Wir laden dann neu und behalten das Demon-Grill.
Imaginäre Demon-Grills-Beste.
Ja, hier kletter ich auch immer in der Kirche hoch.
So weißt du, sonntags einfach mal in die Kirche.
Dann dreimal mit dem Arm da hochgezogen.
Mit einem Arm natürlich nur.
Piss dich an.
Wow.
Also, das...
Das...
Das Demon-Grill möchte nicht ausgetrieben werden.
Und wenn wir das trotzdem machen, passiert das.
Ich schwöre, ich habe deine Seele.
Was hast du getan, mein Sohn?
Du hast dich in Blut verbreitet.
Du hast dich wirklich verbreitet.
Du bist selbstwertig.
Für das Verletzen der Versuchung des unheiligen Feuer,
gebe ich dir ein Gebet der rechten Licht.
Benutz es gut, Sarath, Sohn Isabel.
Benutz es gut.
Wer bist du?
Ein antikristischer Feind deiner Vaters.
Jetzt, geh her und bekleid die Stirn des siebten Drogons,
bis das Weltende in Stahl und Flamme kommt.
So, das passiert in diesem Storystrang, wir kriegen einen geilen Bogen, wir kriegen einen geilen Staff, wir kriegen geile Dagger und wir können unser OP-Schwert anlegen, was wir schon die ganze Zeit im Inventar haben, was wir nicht anlegen konnten, weil wir XANA am Start hatten.
So, und jetzt mag uns das die, wie heißt sie, jetzt mag uns Leana, jetzt findet uns Leana ganz geil und ganz toll und ist übelst scharf auf uns, weil wir uns hier von XANA gereinigt haben, aber wir haben uns ja dazu entschieden, wir wollen XANA behalten, deswegen laden wir jetzt nochmal neu.
Wir machen das jetzt nicht nochmal, ich hole mir bloß die Rüstung.
Ich hole mir nur die Rüstung.
Ne, hab ich auch nicht vor.
So, jetzt aber, der erste Kick hat, oh, oh, der fliegt aber, den hat es zerrissen.
Was zum Teufel geht da ab?
So.
So, jetzt ziehen wir uns die ordentliche Rüstung an und den Typ ownen wir noch.
So, und jetzt hauen wir von diesem Tempel ab.
Und das Gute ist, wir haben jetzt immer noch unsere Demon-Form am Start, weil wir das nicht gemacht haben.
Beste.
Können wir den Endgegner damit später besser ownen.
Hallo.
Drüber springen.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir haben die richtige Wahl getroffen.
Und wenn ihr aufhört, mich zu heilen, dann könnt ihr vielleicht...
Kommt man nicht rein.
Kommt wieder.
Dreh sie weg.
Fuck, ich hab kein Endo mehr.
Arm ab.
Kiste.
In your face.
Wo stellst du die Gegner dann?
Oh.
Ups.
Ich hab die Wache noch geout nebenbei.
Wo ist der Typ?
Da.
Zack.
Ich glaub, jetzt haben wir's.
Du willst mich nicht angreifen, oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich die Typen jetzt kille.
Aber nachdem es kein Gesinnungssystem gibt, kann man eh alles killen.
Oh, was ist das?
Wasser.
Unterirdisch-Stelz-Höhlen-Kram.
Ins Death.
Schild.
Earthfire-Schild.
Nice, das nehmen wir.
Das andere Schild wird gekickt.
Ork-Schild wird gekickt.
Steelball wird gekickt.
Axt wird gekickt.
Kriegt ihr sonst noch was?
Nope.
Oh.
Moment.
Ach, da geht's lang.
Raus da.
Ich hab Hunger.
Das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt, dass wir den Schlüssel mitgenommen haben vorhin, ne?
Also, ich hab gedacht, wir können vielleicht in der Stadt ein paar Türen aufmachen, aber das war...
Debate.
Ein richtiger Debate.
Noch mehr so Viecher.
Ja.
Kommt mal her.
Schreckt.
Oh.
Das sind aber ganz schön viele.
Achtung.
Bein ab.
Nochmal Bein ab.
Tür.
Oh, die geht auf.
Sehr schön.
Ein Quiver.
Moment, hier geht's...
Hier geht's raus aus dem Level.
Ja gut, anderen Weg gibt's ja auch nicht mehr.
Gehen wir hier lang.
Safe.
Bin ich froh, dass das Game vorher nicht geklitscht ist, ne?
Wo der Typ an der Treppe hing.
Sonst hätten wir alles nochmal neu spielen dürfen.
Aber das hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht.
Also jetzt quasi nochmal sechs Stunden nochmal spielen, hätte ich eigentlich keinen Nerv drauf gehabt.
Also, da kann ein Game noch so sehr Bock machen, das gleiche nochmal spielen, einfach weil es geklitscht hat.
Es, glaube ich, hat keiner Bock drauf.
Lightning Shield. Taugt das was?
Das hab ich früher nie genommen.
Weiß bloß nicht mal warum.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Ah, ich hab's nicht genommen, weil das so komisch leuchtet. Genau.
Gehen wir immer auf den Keks.
Au!
Ja, immer viel speichern. Das ist ein guter Hinweis, den wir brauchen.
Wir machen mal einen richtigen Save.
Einen ordentlichen Save.
Oh, Einrichtung schreddern.
Cocktop.
Bread.
Hat er sich angeschlichen von hinten?
Äh übrigens, Zweikampf, zwei Waffen, also Zweihand mit dem Schwert finde ich viel angenehmer als mit dem Schild.
Schild ist immer so nervig, wenn man diese Angriffe macht beim Rennen.
Dann schlägt, dann klitscht er rum und dann schlägt's so komisch.
Guck, trifft man nix.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Wie lang die rumliegen.
Zweihandbeste.
Du kommst dir fast ja vor wie in irgendeinem Vampir-Spiel oder so, wo du aufspießen musst.
Kommt der hoch?
Nee.
Oder vielleicht doch?
Äh, hast du eigentlich mal Proton, äh, Winefuck ausprobiert?
Nee.
Hab ich nicht.
Aber, das ist ja, das ist ja das, was in Steam integriert ist mittlerweile.
Hab gelesen, dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Natürlich hast du die üblichen Probleme.
Dass manche Sachen halt klitschen und so.
Aber, es ist der richtige Ansatz.
Auf jeden Fall.
Mein Valve geht ja auch die Microsoft-Only-Geschichte ein bisschen auf den Sack.
Finden's ja auch nicht schlecht.
Wenn Spiele auch unter anderen Systemen laufen werden, äh, laufen würden.
So können am Endeffekt alle von profizieren.
Aber, bis Games wirklich gut auf Linux laufen und viele Games für Linux kommen, da wird noch ein bisschen Zeit vergehen.
Ja.
Nice.
Nee, das Wasser ist noch zu tief, hat er gesagt, ne?
Oh nee, der kommt hier bestimmt wieder nicht drüber.
Doch.
Zum Glück.
Komisches Rumgeklitsche da von NPCs.
Oh.
Haben wir sonst noch was? Nur eine Potion.
Hier noch was.
Scrolls, wo ich glaube ich im kompletten Playthrough jetzt nicht eine Scroll verwendet hab.
Okay, Wasser.
Wasserreisen.
Den wollte ich eigentlich nicht killen. Ich wollte den Beschwörungsdude killen.
Next. Fuß ab.
So, jetzt werde ich...
Komm her, ihr werdet gekickt wieder.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, vorbei, vorbei, vorbei.
Nächster. Nächster Versuch.
Jawoll, reingekickt.
Oh, den hat's voll reingehauen.
Nice.
Kick. Kick.
Den kommen da noch.
Kopf ab.
Und der auch noch, komm her jetzt.
Bam.
Den hat's... der ist nicht wohin geflogen.
Keine Ahnung wo.
Wasserreisen.
Die Games haben alle immer so ähnliche Quests.
So nach dem Motto, hm, hier komm ich nicht hoch, was musst du machen?
Entweder umlaufen, Brücke hoch.
Irgendwelche Plattformen umschwingen lassen.
Irgendwelche Wasserdinger auffüllen.
Das ist so Standard.
In WoW ist es anders. In WoW müsste ich noch 20 Brücken haben.
In WoW müsste ich noch 20 Blumen für irgendeinen random NPC sammeln.
Muss gucken.
Ah, debated.
Geht nicht.
Kommt man eigentlich hier rauf?
Naja, geht's nicht lang.
Geht's nicht lang.
Bleibt ja nicht so viel.
Ach, was denn hier oben?
Health Potion. Yeah.
Und hier? Nix. Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gewettet, dass da was drin ist.
Das war da so schön versteckt. Man musste einen ordentlichen Jump machen, dass ich gedacht habe, da ist irgendwas drin.
Aber...
Bated.
Was liegt denn da unten?
Das soll ein Baum sein, okay.
Oh.
Dragon!
Hau ab!
Es speit kein Feuer, es speit Blitze.
Auch gut.
Das letzte Viech der Art haben wir in der Mitte vom Game mit diesem Tor gekillt.
Ach, vielleicht kann ich jetzt das...
Ich muss das Viech erstmal killen.
Moin.
C4 Dagi?
Na, wie praktisch.
Hallo, komm her.
Drache, komm her.
Muss ich erst anschießen, dass du herkommst.
Nein!
Wobei.
Alter, bleib stehen.
Hit.
Ich muss mal kurz mich verpissen und heilen.
Wir haben genug Potions bis zum Ende des Games.
Reckt.
Was, F?
Doch nicht, ne.
Das hätte ich mitgekriegt.
Kann nix.
6 Skill Points, kommen wir davon?
Irgendwas gescheites specken.
Hm.
Wird der Master Kleider jetzt sagen.
Ach so, das ist, dass man schneller dahin kommt.
Ich verstehe.
Und wie genau kommt man jetzt wieder hoch?
Gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich einmal umlaufen, das Ganze.
Dann müssen wir oben an dieses komische Rad und dann die Tür aufmachen auf der anderen Seite.
Kann man hier hochklettern?
Geht mal weg.
Alter.
Diese Animation und...
Es will nicht.
Jetzt.
Ne, man kann hier gar nicht hochklettern, ne.
Was ist denn das da?
Kann man das kaputt schießen?
Ne.
Egal, scheiß drauf.
Ich hab genug Potions bis zum Ende des Games.
Ich hab genug...
Ich hab von allem genug bis zum Ende des Games.
Eigentlich brauch ich nicht.
Waffen gut genug.
Ja, jetzt geht die Tür auf.
Schnell.
Weil so schnell müssen wir gar nicht sein.
Wir können ja dahin schleichen.
Sie ist nicht erfreut.
Sie ist überhaupt nicht erfreut.
Oh nein.
Ich kann dich gar nicht weiter lassen.
Es tut mir leid.
Ich wollte das schon seitdem ich die Augen auf den kleinen Chris gesetzt habe.
Ich werde das genießen.
Oh nein.
Ich kann dich gar nicht weiter lassen.
Es tut mir leid.
Ein Clara.
Ich kann dich gar nicht weiter lassen.
participation
Oh nein.
Aber man muss sich tatsächlich in dem Spiel...
Das ist auch ein...
Äh...
Warum klitschst du durch das Tor?
Was soll das?
Nein!
Df?
Ähm...
Ja, man muss sich tatsächlich in dem Game entscheiden...
Und die Entscheidung führt zwangsläufig dazu, dass eine der Hauptcharaktere...
Dass man eine der Hauptcharaktere killen muss.
Die kann aber nix.
Hallo?
Warum trifft das nicht?
Ja.
Ich hoffe, dass du das für eine sehr lange Zeit tust.
Oh ja, mein Lieber, nichts kann dich verletzen.
Wir mussten gerade das Wizard-Grill killen.
Was ist jetzt los?
Alter.
Ah, Ishtar.
Er war ein sehr schlechtes Junge.
Ich habe ihn eher respektiert.
Keine Angst, sein Verletzungen waren gut verdient.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob ich den Zeitraum habe.
Du wirst nicht bleiben.
Hier bist du.
Das Kicken ist das Geilste an dem Game.
Ohne Scheiß.
Das Kicken ist echt das Beste.
Da hatte ich aber Glück, dass ich mich nicht selbst geownt habe.
Oh nein, nicht stunnen, Leute.
Hört auf, mich zu stunnen.
Gestunt wird nicht.
Alter, was ist los hier?
Äh, was?
Was?
Er ist gebuckt.
Er ist entbuckt.
Moin, Sigi.
Bula.
Ich habe es geschafft, alle Beine zu verfehlen.
Und schon wieder stunnen.
Syrus, OP.
Imbar.
Ist er down?
Ja, er ist down.
Da hängt er.
Den wir releasen sollen.
Warum halten die Gegner auf einmal so viel aus?
Oh, nice.
Der andere Typ ist auch down.
Ach so, ja, die halten so viel aus, weil ich nicht das Org-Schwert verwende.
Der buggt irgendwie ein bisschen, oder?
Das ist ein Special-Gegner.
Der sieht anders aus.
Aber der macht nichts.
Der buggt rum.
Und der eigene Typ friendly-feiert ihn gerade.
Genau, Wack.
Du möchtest von mir runtergetreten werden, oder?
Ja.
Du hast ja geradezu danach geschrien, Alter.
Du auch.
Also, der hat ja wirklich schon gesagt, bitte kick mich runter gerade.
Moment, wie soll man hier genau laufen?
So?
So, hä?
So, und du?
Ah.
Ein Seil dran schießen.
Ich mag diese Physik-Gestellte von der Source-Engine.
The fuck?
Jump-Skills.
Outdated.
Ja, kriegst du noch was.
Mit.
Machen wir.
Machen wir alles.
Skill-Points.
13.
Wir können noch.
Wir können.
Vitalitätsbecken.
Automatischer Life-Wreck.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Life-Wreck können wir nie genug haben.
Da stellt sich gerade was ran von hinten.
Der Kick ist geil, ja.
Wird das Beste eigentlich an dem Game.
Also, Kampfsystem-technisch.
Nochmal.
Bäh.
Die normalen Zombies können wirklich gar nichts.
Oder sind das überhaupt Zombies?
Nee, das ist nicht so wirklich, ne?
Das sind auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Untote.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt.
Oh.
Die müssen wir ein bisschen...
Erstmal die Dinger bashen.
Nice.
In your face, Kick.
Oh.
Nix wie weg.
Au.
Macht kaum Damage.
Der sieht nix.
Hä?
Nix wie weg.
Weg, weg, weg, weg.
Okay.
Wie ist denn die offiziell gedachte Taktik hier?
Meint ihr, das geht?
Ernsthaft?
Nice.
So, jetzt müssen wir das Viech nur noch hier reinlocken.
Komm her.
Wo bist du?
Zyklop.
Komm her.
Ja.
Auf...
Da genau.
Dahin.
Da ist gut.
Und jetzt...
Bam.
Äh...
Nein, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Der hat's einfach weggekickt.
Okay, wir müssen...
Wir müssen unsere Jumpslash-Action wieder ausführen.
Das Viech kann überhaupt nix, ne?
Das ist übelst...
Übelst reudig eigentlich.
Einfach ein paar Mal jumpslashen und down ist es.
Ich muss mal was auswählen.
Was passiert, wenn ich vor dem Viech stehe, wenn es umfällt?
Äh.
Nichts.
Hätte ja sein können.
Ich find's schade, dass Half-Life 2...
Also, zu dieser Zeit von Half-Life 2 war es ja voll im Trend,
dass Games so ein bisschen Physik-Zeug dann gemacht haben, also die ganzen Source-Engine-Games.
Ich find's eigentlich blöd, dass sich das nicht etabliert hat.
Es gibt sau wenig Games mit so Physik-Spielereien oder mit glaubhafter Physik zumindest.
Ey, guckt euch mal Skyrim an zum Beispiel, ja?
Da hittet einen irgendwas und man fliegt gefühlt 30 Kilometer über den Berg.
Pilz.
Ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass das hier funktioniert.
Hahahaha.
Oh, die leben noch.
Können wir mal meine Bogenskills...
...auspacken.
Die ungespeckte Level 0 Bogenskills.
Also man sieht, mein Bogen macht mega Damage.
Fast wie der Minecraft-Bogen ungefähr.
Ansonsten ist es ziemlich useless, meine Bogenskills.
Hm.
Was haben wir denn hier so zu bieten?
Aha.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Oh!
Nix gibt's.
Ich lass dich auch nicht stunnen.
Wie der sich heilt.
Hat ihm aber auch nix gebracht.
Next Level Archery.
Da gab's doch so ein Video, ne?
So ein Typ, der dann irgendwie so mit drei Pfeilen im Springen und so geschossen hat.
Aber halt irgendwie nur aus zwei Meter Entfernung.
Mit nem Bogen, der sich wahrscheinlich mit nem kleinen Finger spannen lässt.
Aber da kann ich mich dran erinnern, das war vor ein paar Jahren ja irgendwie so...
...war so ein...
...ziemlich...
...viral Video.
Ich... das hieß doch auch Next Level Archery.
Oder so ähnlich zumindest.
Oh.
Nichts wie weg.
Restores.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Mal gucken, was mit der...
Ah, passiert nix.
So gut ist die Physik-Engine und die Simulation ja dann auch nicht.
Cheater.
Ja, das ist wie bei Dan.
Cheater of...
...Quatsch.
Oder wie das hieß, ne?
Dans Gaming ist bester Let's Player.
Beziehungsweise auch der einzige Let's Player, den ich mir angucken kann.
Der Sarg hat ne Falle.
Das weiß ich noch.
Kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Guckt.
Ähm.
Der hat da...
Ich glaub, da hat er Skyrim gespielt und hat sich irgendwie halt über den Abgrund gecheatet.
Irgendwie sowas war das.
Oh.
Das sind die fetten Gu... die fetten Guards da unten.
Die protec... die protecten.
Aber wir attacken jetzt.
Next, please.
Okay, die sind relativ unbeeindruckt davon, ob sie...
...nen Fass oder sonst was an den Kopf kriegen oder nicht.
Sie sind...
Die halten doch ganz gut was aus, die Jungs.
Die muss man eigentlich aufschießen, dass man sie down kriegt ordentlich.
Was macht das für ne Ultimate?
Das sind die Billigmacher, die können nix.
Was ich geil finde, ne?
Das finde ich auch geil, wie sich die Entwickler gedacht haben.
Wenn ein Gegner wegrennt, habt ihr grad gesehen...
...und man zwickt... man zwitscht auf Dagger...
...kann man den Dagger nach dem Werfen.
Du bist nice.
Guck, der rennt weg.
Dagger switch.
Range kill.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Sind ja immer mehr.
Deckt.
Prepare to die.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Vor allem nicht, wenn man OP 90 HP hat...
...und alle möglichen Skills schon.
Was ist das denn?
Sind die Hand mit dem Dagger in der Hand?
Oh, die haben Harzisch.
Ach das ist der Vater.
Du meinst, dass ich den Jungs nicht ver millones?
Du bist meine Dankbarkeit für seine Freiheit.
Für Leaks.
Leid und Schmerzen sind ausgegangen.
Doch die kommen zu.
Nur um.
Ich werde dich zu punishieren...
Da wird nicht so sehr durcheinander.
Du hast so lange erträgt, die Seele meines Leichens zu tun...
...als Blüter.
Ich freue mich, wenn du mich kennst.
Der geht wohl jetzt für mich.
Na?
Kämpfst du jetzt für mich?
S.
Ja anscheinend.
War gut.
Das ist der Slow-Mo-Guy-Fight, hä?
Die können sich nur in Slow-Motion bewegen und rumkletschen, die Typen.
Rup, rup, rup, rup, rup, rup.
Achtung.
Bam.
Reckt.
Also für das, dass das ein Boss sein soll, sind die ziemlich mies.
Äh, Klitsch.
Wey, bam.
Bam.
Da fliegt er.
Wir kicken den jetzt ins Feuer.
Lol.
Moment, er lebt noch?
Nein, er lebt nicht mehr.
Er musste nochmal aufstehen, um seine Death-Animation abzuspielen und dann vorbei.
Ich glaube, Leute, das ist der letzte oder vorletzte Raum.
Danach sind wir durch.
FeelsBadMan.
Oh, da ist ein Gegner.
Ich sehe nur Blutspritzer gerade.
Ich habe gerade außer Blutspritzer...
...nix gesehen.
Oh!
Wer konnte denn damit rechnen jetzt?
Nein, nein, nein, nicht nochmal.
Ich nehme jetzt mal einen Stein, haue uns demnächst in den Kopf.
Er evaded.
Poggers KI.
Komm her.
Er evaded wieder.
Nochmal.
Lamonitaneier.
Pure Hard.
Wir sind nicht Pure Hard.
Oh.
Die meinen das ernst, oder?
Die meinen das ernst.
Man kann es nicht verwenden, wenn man das Steam-Grill dabei hat.
Egal.
Ich habe genug Leben, ich habe genug Tränke, ich brauche das alles nicht.
Kopf ab.
Bleibst du hier?
Zack.
Direkt.
Ja.
Mit dem...
Mit Dagger kann man werfen, wenn man Special Melee-Angriff hat, also wenn man hier Adrenalin
aufgeladen hat.
Hier ist nix.
Nix.
Okay, Endgegner-Time.
Zieht man das Steam-Grill nochmal?
Ja, ja.
Kommt noch.
Allerdings das, was du dir vorstellst, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder was, was du gerne hättest, wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Weil wir sind hier eher ein familienfreundlicher, christlicher Stream.
Da geht sowas nicht.
Ja, ist bei Demon.
Das ist auch so.
Vor der Ehe läuft da nix.
Wo geht's denn lang?
Da.
Da unten ist er.
The Necromancer.
Erentir.
It's over.
Und jetzt...
Oh.
Lol.
Invisible Stealth.
Wie mir die Zauber von dem kein Damage machen, weil ich...
Weil ich Dings...
Weil ich...
Wahrscheinlich Endo gespeckt hab.
Bam.
Der kann überhaupt nix, der Typ.
Guck mal.
Der kann sich unsichtbar stelzen, als würde man den nicht sehen.
Das ist der schlechteste Unsichtbarkeitszauber ever, den ich kenne.
Easy win.
Durchgespielt! Next game, please!
Okay, G-Bait, es geht auch noch weiter.
Jetzt wird der Dragon geownt. Komm her!
Drache auf den Schwanz hauen!
Alter, was ist das? Ah, hit!
Hit!
Hallo, kann ich den mal hitten?
Wenn ich ihn hitte, bringt nix, ne?
Jawoll, hit!
Ah, jetzt kann ich ihn hitten.
Komm her, Drache!
Ja, komm! Ja, komm!
Mein Damage macht er nicht, wegen meinem Swag.
Hallo, Drache, kannst du mal jetzt runter?
Nope.
Kein Bock.
Mir reicht's jetzt, Leute.
Ich packe jetzt.
Ich packe jetzt meinen Level-1-Bogen aus.
Easy Level-1-Bogen.
Easy Level-1-Bogen!
Level-1-Bogen, beste!
Der leuchtet so, der macht bestimmt gleich Ultimate oder sowas.
Das war ein krasser, ungeskillter Level-1-Bogen gegen den Boss, lol.
Bam!
GG!
In der nächsten Woche ist der D-1-Bogen Final.
Der wird in sehr guten Händen.
Mein Sohn, du bist noch mehr geworden, als ich gehofft hätte!
Ah, das Blut, das fliegt, die Feuer, das schreit!
Bring mir den Wagen!
Der Wagen ist unseres, meine Liebe. Und mit ihm ist das Welt.
Aber ich frage dich das mal.
Brauchst du wirklich deinen Vater zum Regieren, Ahshaan?
Du und ich könnten es ohne ihn machen.
So, letzte Entscheidung des Games.
Wollen wir...
Wollen wir unseren Vater befreien oder wollen wir das Artefakt selbst nehmen und krasser Auna dieses Landes werden?
Ach ja, hätten wir übrigens das Magier-Grill gewählt und nicht XANA, dann hätten wir die Chance gehabt, die Dämonen zu vernichten.
Was wir jetzt nicht haben, weil wir selber einer sind.
Selbst nehmen für...
Selbst nehmen für Big Balls, ja, wir nehmen den selbst.
So, jetzt wirklich GG.
Genug! Ich suche nicht deinen Weg, Vater. Ich suche meinen eigenen Weg. Und ich werde ihn mit der Skala beschreiten.
Einen Tag werde ich frei sein und ich werde dir die ganze Masse von Agonie lehren!
Aus Leid oder Angst wird er entscheiden, ob der Verbrechete allein geblieben ist, die Macht der Relikten noch nicht getappt ist und Aschans Furcht noch nicht.
Und aus Leid wird er nicht geblieben, die Macht, die er nicht geblieben ist, die Macht der Relikten noch nicht.
GG!
Ich habe das jetzt mal wieder gespielt seit 10 Jahren, ist ja schon eine ganze Weile her, das ist immer noch ein geiles Game.
Übelst geiles Game und das Schöne ist halt, dass es auch einen unglaublichen Replay-Value hat, wenn man es überlegt.
Allein schon durch die ganzen...
Also erstmal durch die Entscheidungen, die man treffen kann und vor allem auch durch die unterschiedlichen Ansätze, wie man die Kämpfe machen kann.
Ich meine, man kann das Spiel komplett Stealth spielen, wenn man will, komplett Mage spielen, komplett Bogey spielen, Nahkampf mit ein bisschen Stealth, wie wir es gemacht haben.
Und auch die einzelnen Kämpfe kann man bestimmt jeden Kampf irgendwie auf fünf verschiedene Arten und Weisen machen.
Also das Spiel hat wirklich einen unglaublich hohen Replay-Value.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Ja, ich würde tatsächlich sagen Bad Company 1.
Wenn ich meine DVD finde.
Metro könnten wir allerdings auch machen.
Also ich würde sagen, wir machen Bad Company 1 als nächstes, das ist relativ kurz und knackig.
Wenn ich meine DVD finde, das ist ja der Knackpunkt.
Wenn ich meine DVD nicht finde, dann könnten wir vielleicht wirklich Metro machen.
Nee, nee, Sebarro, Mensch verkaufe ich mir das selbst.
Wir könnten ja auch mal irgendwelche krassen Weep-Games spielen.
Wir könnten es aber auch sein lassen.
Aber das war echt ein geiles Game.
Das hat mir jetzt zehn Jahre später auch wieder gut gefallen.
Leider gab es nie einen Nachfolger, wird wahrscheinlich auch keinen Nachfolger mehr geben.
Sagen wir mal so, der geistige Nachfolger, wenn man sich den Entwickler anguckt, ist Dishonored.
Wobei Dishonored halt mehr Wert auf Stealth legt.
Was sind denn Replays? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne mich da nicht aus, was es da so gibt.
Außerdem sind die meisten Games...
...in der Richtung übelst Grinch.
Das muss nicht sein, ey.
Nur die Neuauflage von Metro.
Ich habe die alte gar nicht.
Ich habe nur Redux...
Redux.
Redux oder so, wie der Franzose sagen würde.
Ich kann ja persönlich kein Wort Französisch, ne?
Ja, ich hoffe, euch hat das Game gefallen.
Ich habe jetzt hier mal eine Pizza stehen, die werde ich jetzt erstmal reinhauen.
Eventuell.
Nur mal so.
Also, vielleicht.
Vielleicht, ja.
Also, muss man sich nicht drauf verlassen.
Vielleicht spielen wir nachher noch eine Runde Black Ops.
Vielleicht.
Aber das ist sehr offen noch.
Vielen Dank fürs...
Ja, danke fürs Zugucken.
Es wäre ja blöd zu streben, ohne dass Leute zugucken.
Und ich finde das hier viel angenehmer, als wenn ich mir heute schon wieder auf YouTube angucke, wie viele Bullshit-Comments unter meinem letzten Video sind.
Ich meine, wir haben zwar mittlerweile wieder 30.000 Views.
Da bin ich immer froh.
Dass ich quasi Voice-Actors, XANA, wer hat die denn gevoicet?
Vanessa Wunsch.
Okay.
Sagt mir nix.
Ach nee, das war nur die deutsche Version.
Das war nur die deutsche Version.
Hast du mal eine Max-FPS bei der Twitch-TV-Emotes gedacht?
Gedacht schon, aber ich habe noch nicht genau angeguckt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Ja, also, ne?
Wir haben zwar wieder 30.000 Views auf dem letzten Video, was ich immer cool finde.
Ja, auch immer.
Nach so langer Zeit, wo ich nichts gemacht habe.
Aber, die Comments sind teilweise wieder so unglaublich dämlich, äh.
Wo ich mich auch manchmal frage, so, erstens haben die Leute das Video überhaupt geguckt?
Haben die Leute das auch nur ansatzweise verstanden, was ich gesagt habe?
Und drittens, wollen sie das überhaupt?
Oder wollen sie einfach nur ihren Dünnschiss abgeben?
Weil so viele Blöds sind dabei gewesen, äh.
Hahaha.
Umlaute können in Credits nicht angezeigt werden.
Ja, UTF-8 ist halt, das ist die hohe Kunst.
Oder generell Unicode.
Das kriegen ja viele nicht hin.
Und außerdem ist das Game von 2006.
Und vielleicht ging es damals unter 2006.
Das kann ja gut und gern sein.
Unter Windows XP oder sowas, der aktuell war.
Es waren 2006 aktuell XP, oder?
Ich habe es ziemlich sicher unter XP gespielt damals.
Ich lasse mal die Credits durchlaufen.
Ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher, ob es noch Post-Credits gab.
Wisst ihr, ich denke mir halt immer, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich anfange nach langer Zeit.
Also ich bin ja manchmal teilweise ein halbes Jahr oder so, wo ich kaum Videos mache.
Und wenn ich dann immer wieder anfange mit Videos und ich sehe, dass das Leute gucken.
Und vor allem, dass man auch direkt, wenn man beispielsweise mal auf, auf Social Blade oder so guckt.
Direkt sieht immer, dass direkt Views hochgehen und Abos hochgehen und alles hochgeht.
Da bin ich eigentlich immer wieder voll motiviert weiter zu machen.
Aber das hält meistens nicht lang.
Das ist so das Problem dabei.
Das ist, ich bin da wahrscheinlich einfach zu, zu, zu Resident Sleeper für irgendwie.
Ich könnte das gar nicht, ja.
Es gibt ja Leute, die, die, die hängen sich da voll rein.
Und machen jeden Tag was, jeden Tag Livestream mehrere Stunden.
Guckt euch den Lost an zum Beispiel, ja.
Videos plus Livestream irgendwie, irgendwie Montana Black oder so.
Ich meine, man kann sich jetzt über die Videos vielleicht streiten, ja.
Aber, ähm, reinhängen tut er sich.
Und den Sellout hat er auch mittlerweile perfektioniert.
Aber ich krieg das überhaupt, ich hab da einfach zu wenig Motivation dazu, mich richtig reinzuhängen.
Hätte ich das die letzten Jahre mal gemacht, denke ich mir immer so.
Dann hätte ich, dann, dann müsste ich jetzt wahrscheinlich Face Reveal machen.
Weil ich denke jetzt genug ab, dass ich zu viel Abos hätte.
Aber ich hab irgendwie nicht so das Durchhaltevermögen.
Durchhaltevermögen, was das anbelangt.
Mich da quasi so übertrieben reinzuhängen.
Monate, Jahre am Stück.
Ich hab mir übrigens überlegt, nachdem ich keinen Bock habe, wirklich Sellout-Videos zu machen.
Ich hab ja früher ein paar gemacht.
Oder auch irgendwelche Promotion, nennen wir das mal Promotion-Videos.
Ich hab ja früher ab und zu welche gemacht.
Und auch die Keyshop-Geschichte und Nvidia-Zeug und sowas in der Richtung.
Eigentlich mach ich ja kaum noch Sellout-Videos.
Und eigentlich will ich auch kaum Sellout-Videos machen.
Das einzige, was ich vielleicht noch machen würde, ist, wenn Nvidia sagen sollte,
Hey Max, willst du nicht wieder eine neue Grafik haben?
Dann würde ich sagen, okay, klar.
Wenn wir es genauso machen wie das letzte Mal, bin ich wieder dabei.
Aber so allgemein hab ich eigentlich gar keinen Bock, irgendwelche Sellout-Videos zu machen.
Die gehen mir immer auf den Keks.
Ich mach die auch ungern.
Deswegen hab ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach, anstatt dass ich irgendwelche Keyshop-Geschichten, Sellouts wieder mache.
Oder irgendwelche...
Promotion-Sellouts.
Ob ich mir nicht einfach einen Patreon-Account oder sowas mache.
Da kann nämlich im Endeffekt jeder, der Bock hat, quasi, nennen wir es mal was, was donaten.
Was auf jeden Fall mir hilft und was bringt.
Und ich muss keinen Sellout machen.
Oder T-Shirts verkaufen oder irgendwie sowas.
Das ist auch sowas.
Da hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Jetzt haben jetzt schon viele Leute gesagt, sie hätten gerne ein Max-FPS-T-Shirt oder so.
Wie?
Ich bin enttäuscht.
Aber da bin ich auch zu faul für.
Nachdem ich keinen Bock auf Sellouts mache, hab ich mir überlegt, vielleicht mach ich mir einen Patreon-Account.
Da kann dann wirklich jeder, jeder der Bock hat und der nicht Bock hat, lässt bleiben.
Es ist ja keiner irgendwie verpflichtet oder...
Ich bin ja auch nicht wirklich drauf angewiesen, auf die Kohle.
Ähm...
Lass mal gucken.
Aber Patreon wird schon erwartet, dass man dann aktiv Content macht.
Ich denke, dass das Wichtige ist, was ich da drauf schreibe und was ich halt sage.
Ja.
Da geht's halt einfach darum, dass...
Soll sich da keiner irgendwie zu verpflichtet fühlen.
Wenn jetzt aber zum Beispiel einer sagt, hey Max, ich guck jetzt...
Und das schreiben ja viele.
Ähm...
Ich guck jetzt schon die letzten 10 Jahre dein Content.
Da war so viel dabei, was mir gefallen hat.
Ich mach...
Wir machen jetzt mal ein paar Monate Patreon.
Ist ja auch ne super Geschichte.
Jeder wie er will, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich bin ja auf die Kohle nicht angewiesen.
Außerdem hab ich die letzten Jahre über genug Sellout gemacht.
Ich hab auch ein bisschen was gespart.
Also...
Geldmäßig ist eigentlich kein Problem weiter.
Ich hab hier das Haus vom Opa.
Prost.
Ich hab auch keine Miete oder so bezahlen.
Also an sich geht's mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich werd kein YouTube Millionär mehr.
Sowohl in Abos als auch in Kohle.
Sehr wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber das muss ja auch nicht sein.
Ist ja eh bescheuert.
Wozu?
So.
Mach mal aus.
Quit.
Wen könnt ich denn hosten?
A link to the past speedruns könnt ich hosten.
Das machen wir mal.
Das guck ich immer gerne.
Das guck ich jetzt auch beim Essen.
Okay Leute.
Ähm.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Ich geh jetzt meine Pizza futtern.
Und ein bisschen Speedruns gucken.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
See you.